each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
um so it's a pleasure to introduce ping
Li his back once again to msi has done
three internships with us to earth can't
judge someone with me he's finding
finishing his PhD the statistics
department of Stanford with river hasty
and I love to work on dimensional
reduction and stuff like that and that's
what it's going to talk about say there
are some slots if anybody wants to talk
to him who's not already so just see me
after the talk and we will arrange that
thanks alright thank you for coming so
my pleasure to be here thanks Chris oh
let's do this okay so today I'm going to
talk about two methods for approximating
distances why is it called stable random
projection another method called
conditional random samplings and I like
to thank my this is a visor travel hasty
and the collaborators can so sleep so
let's start with that with the slides
now we are lucky or unlucky in the era
of modern massive data sets and the part
of the talk about a quarter will present
it in a workshop and this summer and
before the summer and the workshop was
the goal of the workshop is to bridge
the goal a bridging the gap between the
numerical linear algebra theoretical
computer science that data applications
and it was request successfully had a
lot more participants than what we end
originally anticipated most of them from
yahoo and google because it was at
Stanford so this is our two sentences a
week everybody loves you never pay you
think until you run out of data there's
no data like more data and they owe this
one so this is our favorite slides and I
won't tell you who where the slides
coming from but basic says that if we if
we use more data eventually you're going
to get more equities and no matter what
which matter you're doing thanks Eric
okay okay so as their two properties are
larger data sets so first larger data
sets are often highly sparse and and
everyone knows that text data most of
the words only occur in less than one
percent of documents and the so we
should take advantage of that and the
end in the summer and the summer 2007 I
will be giving another talk in in a
session the mms end of meetings on
sports paucity of high dimension
problems so another property or larger
data sets is a data set often had highly
heavy-tailed so this goes back to our
preto rules a Pareto principle like
eighty percent 20 8020 rule says eighty
percent of the population owns a twenty
eight twenty percent of population also
eighty percent of the money this is a
public not true in Microsoft but I will
have many examples it is it sure not
sure well so have you tell data brings
challenges both challenges and
opportunities to learning and to
business and to information retrieval so
so this is a sea doesn't
okay so this is a cover page of a book
tells you how to do business you using
the long tail distributions that means
numerous number of small transactions
well in the end bring your lots of
fortunes because of because they have a
tail so what the heavy tail data really
look like so so heavy tail heavy tell
that are usually modeled by like preto
distributions with parameter theta so
the probability density of preto is this
power law forum that's why it's also
called power law distributions and if we
plot the probability density with
different ate our values we can see that
compared with the normal curve which
drops really quickly so the tale of the
distributions it become really theory
relatively flat even at very large the
value of x and an important property
over this Pareto distribution is that if
a gamma is larger than ETA it doesn't
have moments and the paper gamma less
than less than a 10 it has a finite
gamut moments so there many people
killed measurements over a tie night gas
this is from the new paper and we can
see that a lot of the values are between
12 maybe slightly less than 1 but
slightly larger than to you arranging in
that range so this this shows that most
of the data points most of the data sets
they do not have bounded for second
moments because 8 has a nest at two but
most of that upsets they have at least
boundary first moments because 8 has a
larger than one for most of data sets
and so this also means in terms of
moment so we can talk about the norms we
can also talk about norms so that means
L 2 norm which is the Euclidean distance
is often do not make sense in most of
data sets but the l1 norm which is also
known as a Manhattan distance are
usually meaningful and so that their for
today's talk I'm going to talk about
three different three different topics
the first topic is about using stable
ran a projection to approximate the air
offer norms offer between 0 & 2 it's a
very theoretical appealing and I'm going
to show a little bit
about the radical results for that topic
but what we really like is the idea of
very sparse stable random projections
which improves the efficiency very
considerably and both of this result has
not been published and they're submitted
to their preprint server and but the
prior work is called very sparse random
projections and is published in k TD and
but I won't talk about that today since
I'm more excited about the new results
so that so they're not another algorithm
called conditional random sampling and
we develop or not why was the intern
here it's often which works better than
random projection because you takes
advantage of data sparsity and and we
like it because we use the same schedule
for many different tasks for many
different summary statistics and it has
a strong connection to brothers and well
known algorithm come in white sketches
so this is a gender so this little bit
notation will over use a capital letter
a to no data matrix or n rows and
d collins that means and data points and
D dimensions so some examples like a
turn document matrix Sony's number words
and these number of documents and the
onion d can be huge and we'll have those
customer product matrix it also has this
uh everybody a lot of people excited
about the million-dollar price machine
learning task to do a user movie rating
and and also the image of pixel matrix
or gene expression microarray data so
just a little bit review of the
distances and so the pairwise distances
are fundamental now for example the l
alpha distance which is basically the
basically the absolute difference raised
to the offered power and some overall
coordinates and we also will everybody
loves a coordinate at the inner product
or cosine distance which is normalized
inner product or center cosine inner
product cost center cosine distance
which is a correlation distance or chi
square and mutual funds and in some
application will care also about the
motorway distances we should also occur
yet a motorway intersections a motorway
intersections
okay so the last numerous applications
based on distance is like classification
clustering duplicate remover the nearest
neighbors and recommender system
database query optimizations retrieval
and the Colonel's know about distances
so before we're talking about some
challenges so the first question basic
question is what distance you will use
and the also means in which the norm
show should I work with and we everybody
love to use l2 distance like and the
many of the statistical models and
learning model they assume normal or no
more like that has bound your second
moments but all where is not no more
well unfortunately unfortunately to live
in abnormal word so what you would do
because the l2 distant doesn't make
sense in most of data sets so so people
do like what people do is that well we
just love with l2 norm so let's stick
with it so let's let's knit must listen
maneuver the data so let's turn with the
data in its the user for example you
square root of data i take a locker ism
or the binary quantize the data or the
second solution is on this user error
after norm are for less than two or some
for example we know that l1 norm is
usually meaningful for most of data sets
so let's use that or just need to use
any other offer that can be as a tuning
parameter that so there's a hybrid
approach to so cv c h u v V stands for
web- for name recognition they suggest
the SVM Colonel this form so inside the
inside explain show the current the
colonel meet basically the offer
distance on the weighted data and they
say well alpha equal point five
sometimes it works best for that
specific task so so this is a some
background information why do we care
about our offer distances so let's now
talk about some channel some
computational challenges in distance
based methods so the first challenge is
that that are often too large to fit in
the physical memory so we do need a
compact data representation and sometime
if you want the computer all pairwise
distances it just keeps
it's not feasible and the four motorways
404 pairwise but for multi way sometimes
just getting worse it's just it's just
getting worse and in some application at
database applications we can absolutely
care about about speed for example we
want to use some quick and dirty
estimates or joints and to do a career
planning so obviously you want this
estimates to be done really quickly a
better much quicker than executing the
current their actual plans and then
there's a another problem is a massive
data stream problem I'm not sure that's
a problem in Microsoft buying some other
company like AT&T is a big problem
because I have lots of a network traffic
and highway traffic and weather
conditions of Finance data and the data
is so large is sometimes you don't even
store the data you just stood on summary
statistics so a computing the summary
statistic and updating it become a
challenging and in some area that have
management's so okay so so now the first
solution for dust for dinner with the
massive data sets is that let's do
random coordinate sampling so instead of
instead of using dealing with the data
matrix it was D comments which B is a
huge so let's do a subsample that means
we choose K auto d comments from data
matrix and the getter get us more
reduced matrix code 88 tilta and then we
just approximate any any with a summary
statistic by the by the sample summary
statistic x scale so this is good it's
because it is simple and so people use
every day I guess and it's another thing
people like it because it can be reused
for approximately all kinds of distances
so once one samples for all so this is
great but you have been criticized over
and over because the air is very large
and you when the data are cited a model
as slightly have you told the error is
quite large I mean talking about the
various and when when we were working
with a sparse data the most examples
will be zeros
if you fix the number of columns so
that's the just two main criticism for
random coordinates anthony List let's
see why the valency is very large and
then so let's look at example so suppose
we have x1 and SD coordinates and the
ranting to pick K out of the elements
and estimate the original after norm
then the variance will be in this form
if I hope you can be convinced this is
the truth because the very thing about
variance of x is x squared minus CX the
whole thing squared so and this because
we're working with the afternoon about
this turn did is raised to that you are
for power that means is the dominating
turn when the variance when the data I
have it held so it is a killer so the
numerous ways how to remove this heavy
tail at the impact of the heavy coat and
though we're going to discuss discuss
about two methods once called stable
random projections not the metaphysical
conditional random sampling to really
true to reduce the variance so using
stable random projection this is just
advertisement i'm going to show you the
results later again so stable and
projection so the variance becomes this
form so instead of this to offer I don't
have the to offer anymore so remove the
variance and with the see the small
constant so which sort so that's why
people are excited about because you
remove the heavy the impact or heavy
tetanus so people think that's great ok
send an end but we like this up with an
even better we could conditional random
sampling it after after and our
algorithm has the same form of variance
as regular rental coordinate sampling
except it multiply multi political term
of spasticity which is sometimes often
less than point 01 in some applications
so both both matter reduce the variance
compared with the random coordinated
sampling in different ways and whether
or not CRS is better than srp depends on
how heavy is the data and house process
the data so there's no conclusive answer
except in the boolean data which is also
which is
which is not so smart I wish is boss and
also not very heavy tail we know that
conditional random sampling is a way
better than stable random projections
okay just some okay so let's start with
the stable rental possessions so stable
and the projection the idea is another
complete nut it's not that complicated
means and we have a big matrix a and
then we don't like it because too big so
let's multiply that with a small matrix
small skinny matrix R and we get another
skinny matrix B so B is we call
projected data matrix so r is the
projection matrix so the entries are a
random in the sense that each elements
or are there samples of alpha stable
distribution and this when alpha is good
too that's normal let me use a normal
samples when alpha is one that's cause
she and the projected data contains
enough information to reconstruct their
offer distance in a and our contribution
here is that we provide a good estimator
to recover the distance and this
variance and bounds and the this Jo type
of lemons for all alpha so this is the
new theoretical results and the but we
like the idea of where sports table and
projections because this isn't that this
multiplication is it going to be very
expensive and we don't want to do that
and this will at least we want to do
that more efficient way so so so I'm
going to talk about that too all right
so before i get into the theoretical
results let's let's talk about some
experiments so this is experiment on
classifying the gene expression gene
micro microwave data here my exam my
data is not too large it had only 176
data points in 12,600 dimensions is it
considered a high dimension even though
it's not very not too high so that the
data points belong two or three
different classes tunic answers to
cancer classes and one normal samples
and if we do an actor using the l2
correlation distance and and the
newest neighbor classifier you're going
to make like us for 26 mistakes auto
auto 176 but if we use the l1 distance
the error is much much smaller so so
this is just example shows well l1
distance works better than a or two okay
but what are we going to do is that
we're going to do stable random
projections that means we have the data
and we multiply that with the random
matrix R and this the dimension where r
is twelve thousand six hundred and x kk
ranging from five to four hundred and
then we're going to do two different
kinds of experiments why is a stable and
projection that means in this case one
case is a Cauchy so so r has a Cauchy
entries in one experiment and not
experiment are has this strange
distributions which is a mixture of
Pareto we already seen crater and it was
with lots of zeros in the middle and we
can see that we win a bait hides verse
more like a point of one that means
ninety-nine percent with them are zeros
so so we can do both experiments then we
just estimated original l1 distance in a
from the projected data be using the
estimator I'm going to talk about later
and then we do the classification your 5
News neighbor and using l1 distance is
using the estimated l1 distance and then
it will repeat experiment 100 times and
average is a curve so this is what we
get so this is so it's so this contains
lots of information so the horizontal
access means the sample size that means
how much what can you do and the
vertical access is the the Miss
classification errors and then you want
no arrows and you want you ideally you
want no errors and no work you want here
which is which is not possible so so we
have to do some work and this horizontal
line means means using the old 12,000
dimensions you get two arrows okay so
and this this curve the dashed curve the
koscheck the red curve koshi curve
means using caution and the projections
and that you reduce the dimension from
12,600 to about 100 dimensions and the
you the arrows up as a comparable as a
relatively small so this is good as a
cautionary position it can reduce the
dimension vary considerably without
hurting the performance of Allah so now
the three curves go beta corresponding
to this this type of projections the
sports projections and that we can see
that the beta equal to point 01 is still
overlap with the Koshi that means we get
100 full speed up compare the cushion in
the projections without hurting the
performance of course if you do like a
little bit too extreme now point 0 0 1
you're going to see some difference but
still but yeah but still it's not it's
not too much too much difference
opponents the your ignoring with those
different values of beta the fractions
are is the factions of 1 minus beta so
beta is beta is a for example bait has a
point 01 thank you been at the point 1
means the ninety-nine percent of the
projected of the projection matrix are
are zeros more in ninety nine percent
and then ignoring ninety-nine percent I
still get a comparable results I mean
actual overlapping results yeah so there
must be a huge amount of redundancy in
this dataset yes yes that's a yeah
that's not a way to look at it yeah the
average of one hundred a big area I
think I look at the various yeah all
right yeah but it said that the actually
the very small when i look at the
ability not recorded the variance is
about i think the difference between i
go out to the missing misc Africa heroes
usually yeah its rate using the Pareto
distribution there is very important
like if you use data distributions there
where they are values this is what not
there is also be different and the Plato
you well you the reason that because
we're working with a l1 distance so you
have to use that
they call like that the distribution
praises belong to the family called make
a stable teacher nico de mayo which
domain over her trash your family so you
have to use something i could pray to or
something similar to do that and you can
i use normal for 401 yeah so this is for
unsupervised projection I am so go bad
possession here with your Chris purchase
he would use something like multiple
screwed analysis have you tried that
even you might only get three dimensions
out but but you know can you squeeze
much harder if your projections were
informed about the project about the
tasks we're trying to do instead of
trying to river in I haven't tried that
by I believe for the status s since he
works so well that means I believe there
and and the supervisor will also give a
very good results here doing relations
yeah yeah yeah I should try that thank
you try and say different piece
different beta house or initiative oh
yeah the theoretical analysis is based
on the negev rate of convergence
analysis is anak generalized central
limit theorem and how fast it grows when
beta is more the rates of convergence
very slow so eventually yeah you
eventually is going to break and you're
saying it's already broke and yeah it's
done look well third from here I can't
see yeah that the reason that once you
once you get it to 100 dimension that
means you're actually in a way you you
accomplish it that little beta values
already yeah so really say yes the
dimension gets actually very high haha
that's the sample size gets high in fact
things really aren't as they aren't
being as fast as later it's really
implying uh-huh yeah but what you say I
I think that's one of the reasons yeah
because because you do the projection
independently so that means if you as
not the assembly enough eventually going
to touch every element yeah yeah
so you're evaluating this on
classification yeah nearest neighbor
classification so is nearest neighbor a
good method for this are other methods
comparative I haven't tried I guess it's
not yeah but I haven't tried any other
matters so the purpose to show this the
show that the Koshi render projection
works and the verse fast doesn't affect
much of the performance yeah but yeah I
consider this a toy example so do not
try any other really my question about
the various what was the worst case
because in this case right it could be
that 99 percent of the time you get a
good result and once with your random
projections your the variable result but
when your eyes are real weight that you
only write it once you don't damage any
time you lose the advantage right so
what kind of guarantees you have about
the performance well there's no
theoretical guarantees for four
classifications there's theoretical
there's of theoretical guarantees in
terms of distances but come about going
from distant to classification is
another it's not a procedure there's no
theoretical guarantees on that so I am
going to talk about there are
theoretical guarantees in terms of
distance yeah but yeah thank you next
time I'm going to plot the puzzle
variants on it yeah if that's what
readers 500 don't personhood my descale
are one why is this why she wants using
pmac so i could just scale along and get
excited to get a sale distance all the
peas change I'm just the same word why
not you just been awful greater variable
scale let's scale the our matrix okay in
seven days okay then p offer there's a
two BR I mean it's a your distance is
with what's going on oh yeah that's fine
yeah by doing the estimation you have to
you have to consider the scale scale
near I knew it in order to recover yet
skinny is a fine skinny that doesn't
matter I guess yeah the importance is
the sparsity
yeah okay maybe hey go on so it's a
little bit background on stable
distributions so stable distribution can
be so it's a density you cannot use you
to write it down explicitly exactly you
can write it down in terms of Fourier
transforms so stable distribution has
this Fourier transform and R&D means the
offer parameter is the index parameter
these are scale parameter I use a
capital s to indicate that and so in two
cases we know that we know the Fourier
transform me we know the inverse Fourier
transform so it's normal and a co she
that x to the i xt there is actually
giving us what that's kind of like the
frequency so basically what we're
looking at what you're saying is in the
frequency domain and the the energy
needs to drop off exponentially is that
we have frequency is that roughly at
that time yeah I think so we really
where alpha is that it how fast it grows
you know folks how fast you are fanatics
particular by power Lord all over me
eggs yeah so there's an exiting in front
of this place tonight are you reading
the forum yeah you're like a so this
will that hasn't works principle
yeah you can't you want amazing Apollo
in other domains not right spring sure
so so you cannot have both so this is a
think it's related to their hash but it
has Christmas it has a books principal
right yes yeah okay so this is so this
is normal and this is Cauchy so normal
is so cause you look like normal in
their hair but the tail is much thicker
okay so what's stable me stable ye
terminals are no more and we probably
very familiar with it because if you x
is normal and therefore any weights you
you you do a normal adult weight your
sound is still normal but with the
variance becoming the l2 norm of the
vector you so that means that that means
now after after the summation is still
no
that's y equals stable but for general
alpha is still have similar form except
the scale parameter instead of the l2
norm becomes alpha norm so so that's why
it's called stable and it's so therefore
this provides a natural mechanism to do
to mention reductions so so let's so
let's look at this figure again so a is
the original data matrix R is a
projection matrix has this stable
distributions B is the project data so
if we only look at the first two rows
the u1 and u2 a and a v1 of your
choosing be so they have this
correspondence so v hv has k dimensions
so each dimension of V is a stable with
scale parameter Amy with index parameter
alpha and the scale parameter being the
L alpha norm in vector u1 and it's the
difference they also distributed as the
same scale pram I mean the same stable
distribution was different scale
parameter which happen to be the l alpha
distance between u 1 and u 2 sensor what
you're saying there is that if all the
variables and I are distributed
according to this particular family is
the scale parameter with alpha hat right
then B is going to be some linear
combination of those very yes and then
that will then also belong to that same
family the variables in vivo also bought
yes yeah thank you yeah the linear
combination can see from here is a
matrix multiplication yeah thank you
yeah but for any are you know I thought
it was any are I thought it was any
linear combination yeah anyone it'll be
a linear combination yeah he wouldn't be
stable
oh okay is it any hour or is it the
right out that well there are alpha I
mean aqua has to between zero and chill
right so that for any are between an
alpha pitch India and two so the Aqua
still still stays the same that means
but probably more cancers does any full
for the right arfa so you have to choose
alpha from your problem you want to work
with yeah that's on your problem yes how
about depending of problem so depends on
whether so you need to iPod the size
that the variables in a hear from some
stable distribution alpha you know with
with parameter alpha but then tribute
the case of any are right yes I
understood your formula curry yes be
will also come from that same stable
district yes and the so apples after the
projection yeah you will get the stable
distribution stay brand of variables so
so the only thing you to do did you ask
them mate the scale parameter once you
could ask if you could estimate it then
you're done with the state brand new
projections okay so so this yeah so the
Skee so the so the problem amounts to
ask the meeting the scale parameter
stable distributions from k samples you
may also i mean that you know the Alpha
your pick alpha so estimating the scale
parameter D ya do ya how many
generations and from k samples yeah so
so you become a statistic estimation
problem and it's not straightforward to
estimate it because it's the first
question asked is i can't we just ask
them about the meat but sample mean like
this you well it's good it's good
estimated when alpha is equal to so this
is a great estimator is unbiased is
optimal it's the same as maximum
likelihood and it's obvious and it has
this that we know the DJ bution is gamma
distribution or chi square so we know
the moments of another tale balance and
this this famous el msj lemma says we
only need the k to be as small as an
eggnog and over a personal square to get
the arrows bounded by 1 plus minus
epsilon
so so we know everything about the l2
case yeah so so this is good but as soon
as I for less than two so this thing
doesn't work when alpha less than one
but it doesn't work too well when office
pitching while I nachu so we need to do
a different estimator and well we can
always ask me the parameter by maximum
likelihood because because we can
represent the distribution by by Fourier
transform so we can do maxim like her
you one but which is not practical for
this problem of this scale because we
have two numerical evaluate the
probability density except in three
cases and I worked out the last case i
recently work law is very very beautiful
results i like i like it but I I don't
want to present here and there so people
ask why we care about our go to 0 that
corresponding to the Hammond or so
people you people care about a Hammond
or this is a good so and they produce a
very end the distaff likelihood
estimator is very good for that but we
propose estimators of simple estimator
is based on the geometrical me so this
is estimator you can order complicated
denominator if you look at only look at
the numerator is bit is the geometric
mean of the sample and the is unbiased
and the denominator is complicated but
we can pre-compute it because it's just
basically a bunch of gamma function and
it has very simple asymptotic form and
we know that when alpha equal to 1 this
as methodically become one and the pupil
probably remove it is constant just oil
is constant so this is the estimator
we're using we recommend ii also stories
you know
oh because we picked off our yeah so
they may not redistribute it that way
right just giving Jason uh-huh yeah this
given that huh you have to yeah that
that's different problem yeah it's a
different power point so you will just
say you yeah and estimate the offer that
should pretty pretty difficult it's more
difficult than estimating scale
parameter yeah and it's difficult but
it's different problem like you I
present a table people i should estimate
this alphabet I mean this is valueless
yeah but it's different problem so here
we just say suppose we pick off i equal
to 101 then what's the what's the
estimator okay so this is estimated
we're dealing with yeah we're using and
as I promised the variances in have this
form like a the scale parameter to the
square to turn and over K so and there's
little constants depend on alpha yeah
and how and then how good is this
estimator there's a way if it under I
still were worried about what is the
variance how good is that so so and we
know that mle is asymptotically optimal
so we just compare against ml e.m le is
in feed is not practical to do but at
least we can say it's directly how bad
is it compared with ml e so you will be
always lot as always worse than ml ye as
at least as imperfectly but we can if we
plot the efficiency is this that means
so the the the vertical access it goes
to from 0 to 1 so maximum is one you can
do as good as a one hundred percent of
the mle but when offers between a point
six to one point one is eighty percent
is good and if we were only interested
in l1 norm that means this is very good
estimator and in the worst case and at
point 4 so in the offer you to too but
when are you could kill you don't you
don't use this you use something simpler
okay so all right so for people care
about hair bands and we provide the tail
bound 6 the
theoretical tail bands and that means
they estimated value compared with the
original should be within epsilon
fraction and has explained shalida k
probabilities so and and I don't want to
show other one expressed this explicit
because it complicated form but we can
party them so it's a reasonably small
small parameter for alpha it's okay so
for people who care about GL llamas from
the exponential tail bands you can get
the jail lemma says well we only need a
k2 logarithm Ln and over epsilon square
so that means in produce if we prove the
GL type of lemma 40 alpha so this is a
older theoretical results i want to say
about it and so and we can infer you're
interested in estimation yeah and happy
to talk about it but all this and the
ulema said yeah maybe it your video is
so that means using our estimator as not
as long as the using k is in the order
of a lockin of epsilon squared so the l
alpha distance between any pair if you
have any data point between any pair
with the point pairs and points can be
estimated within 1 plus minus epsilon
factor yeah which you may know how much
how many dimension want to choose yeah
service for l1 those still is no gee and
they like or it's impossible to have one
sorry because the third thing that for
l1 know and there's no JLM max or yes
that's exactly not video that's
absolutely right but i just say this
analogous so that means as long as we
just want we just want to estimate the
distance whether or not this parameter
whether or not this estimator is a
metric or now I don't care so this is
not a magic that's why is that's why
they are the jail lemma does not exist
if we insist estimator had a good metric
yeah yeah thank you for for yeah I was
trying to avoid like to talk about
yeah yeah but it's not a magic that
means some application is not it's not
very good but if you only care about
distance it's okay but if you want to do
like some applications some applications
require requiring a metric then it's not
good thank you oh that the constant is
small yeah well of course I mean Epsilon
what about if you go to high dimensions
how does the histogram of Lal alpha
distance scale with the dimension it
also goes to a drag version yeah that's
a very that's very good questions like
and like we just say that out apps no
but Absalom contains a lots of
informations and it's really up to the
problem when you're working with a bit
puts the Pacific problem how to pick
epsilon is a big is big problem yeah
theoretically is very beautiful but that
the jail lemma had this problem so how
to pick a personal yeah thank you for
look for the regarding the crackhouse
move the constant it's a constant is the
related with this constant which is very
small yeah like for that's why it's very
useful otherwise these useless yeah
thank you so so now so now where we so
we we do that we do the code we do the
stable random projections we estimate
hitting with so we're so we're doing
good but now the problem is how the
sample from a coding form stable
distribution you have to this a problem
we have the address so it's in look
quite simple we just a sample neck
sample form in uniform the example form
explain show then do this a simple
algebra we get a disability as a coach
as a stable well we don't want to do
this this is this is horrible so you
want to do something much simpler so
yeah so so therefore yeah this is our
recommendations so is instead of using
doing this business let's do no preto
and the end with with do preto with with
the high sparsity that means instead of
using s offer one we do so this
distribution has lots of benefits first
example is much easier because you know
how to get a state preto we just sample
from uniform then then scale and then
raised to the power again we get at the
operator and the the costs are computing
the matrix multiplication is much
reduced by the factor of a bait on a
beta so if a bait has a negative point
or wound in reduced by a negative sort
of a hundred for speed up and the story
in there are storing this matrix R is
much reduced to why do you want to store
the matrix or the last reason you want
to do it because for example the new
data points on me calm and the data
point may change so that's that's why
you want to store it and it's actually
big storage costs but this will reduce
the cost we're considerably okay so this
is a rather look like if you want to
look read the red portion so this is the
hour of our recommended distributions so
it has a Pareto tail and a big point
mass in the middle so this will
guarantee there where you shoot the
sparsity okay so the two fundamental
reasons why this are looking things
should work the reason the first reason
that the data should be reasonable for
example when we're using the l want this
norm waiting place they assume that the
data has at least boundary first moments
otherwise this is pointless to do l1
norm and the second reason that the
dimension t is very large otherwise
there's no point doing dimension
reductions and when it is so large and
the asymptotic analysis becomes almost
the exact nemesis because he is so large
and another intuition that we because
this is so large they can afford to only
use a fraction of
coordinates next beta times D and then
they do the projection on those
coordinates and they repeat that K times
it's so so this two fundamental reason
why it works but the erratic analysis is
related to the and to the general to the
to the to the generalized sentiment
there but and if probably not many
people care much about it that means if
the projected data is still each ability
as a stable with the same scale
parameter but with the same scale
parameter x a different scale parameter
a different scale and they the scale
doesn't matter because you can always
skip back so as not as data has bounded
off for some moments so this is a very
natural requirements and the you foo and
they and then we can do a little bit
better if we know if if we know that
data has more than offers moments for
example neck when the data has a
boundary second moments and alpha is
less than one then we can choose the
beta so small like 1 over square root of
D that rate is still very large as it's
the rate is still very fast so it's all
about radar for the rate of convergence
and also and the sparsity and and the
old critically depends on how logic d is
so that's why it works if the if the
higher moments abound the higher moments
exists and in fact actually you can get
away with more spots representing yes
yes is that true yeah and the more the
more higher moments of course I was is
larger than to a lot larger than higher
margin a second higher than second
moments then doesn't help anymore but
yeah but before that the more the more
higher moments you have the most paucity
can't afford yeah so that's a yeah so
did I assure this results in the food
for the food for the people already know
there are no those kind of results for
for the I for
IDK so when the when the r is a why I
mean the U is one so it's well known in
the etching in nineteen nineteen
twenties or thirties and Alex probably
is all from Russian and but when when it
started the race of convergence when
when the U is not because we need to
consider you is none iid so that's the
theoretical a little bit theoretical
part is that when the study the rate of
convergence and non idks if ya so so we
use here are going to be like features
or something else like that New York and
of course you wouldn't expect those to
be already right no it's because yeah
it's not going to be ID yeah so yeah but
I wrote that in a preprint so so the
experimental results we want to look at
is a that we order to see this will have
a microarray data and the another that
help I'm not to look at is a nice
routine that good data when the data
eight operator and a test data is a
point one point five I and a tattoo and
also trust do some Microsoft amazing
Weber crow data so this is the
experiments for the big article data
let's look at this form that this point
that means with the data file the pareto
is a heavy tail but because of this
parameter a tie to that means the pretty
it's pretty decent then I Cal for very
small beta so beta here is a no point
like almost naked minus three quarters
she's very very very small beta but
still get very good results so the
results here is that I can sample size
as an vs omega the mean square error and
the theoretical curve means the curve is
using stable distributions using am
using stable distributions and they're
so the other curves corresponding to D
is an egg 180,000 these 500 we can see
that we can see that we can afford this
first boss projections when these are
like a 500,000 so we don't need to very
large you take a good results for the
for this case
story in XXL 10 doesn't that to hide
some terrible result from 0 to 10 or
sample size so I presented yeah so so
with less than 10 yes just increase and
and so the point is that it's actually
it's it matches the theoretical
predictions so theoretical predictions
that is this is its overlap with this so
so yeah certainly or when when a case
less than 10 yeah and and and oh and I
did not product because i want to see
here otherwise you cannot see he come
and seen this part yeah all right sorry
can you remind us where the theoretical
predictions are coming from theoretical
predictions theoretical positions are
assumed that the data are here where
we're talking about the l1 l1 norm so
assume that the data are exactly our
coach I mean the projection our cost
projections and then we know the
variance of cost projections so this is
the theoretical curve for the cost
projections and so the point is that
using spots projection well actually
actually matches the cost projections
you yeah even so such a sports
conditions that yeah for this but this
is just the radical data from none
theoretical data like I mean not in
tactical data this a web crow data shows
the two pairs of words and and because
the data are heavy heavy tailed
especially for this is just two pairs
and the dimensional 65,000 and that i
use the char different beta values now
point one point or one point and they
eventually has case we expect guy
eventually couldn't break but when it
bait has a point of one that basically
corresponding to 1 over T to the point
six point point for so which is which is
still very sparse and get very very
close results
the darkness my words yeah the count
that means that documents the count
that's a document contained the word
yeah and I did I yeah contained that
word I me know the how many times they
were occur in that document yeah so this
is the obvious very heavy tail
distribution and the you Lewis yeah it's
a highly heavy-tailed education and
another reason it doesn't work too well
for this case it because this much
sponsor so the yeah so the D is not
actually is not that be yeah Saudi
there's he is that we used to go camry
your documents another document talking
yeah only two O's yeah only two rows on
it on to loose stools so these number of
documents and the end the only two rows
like this and half neck to two rows so
that means that the data are the number
of occurrences of that word in the
document initial one over the documents
so most of them some of them will be
zeros actually may be tempting to ninety
percent of them are zeros but lots of
them lots of documents that contain the
big numbers occur in bignum pick a
number of times yeah so it's a yeah OMSI
i miss sorry wooden square error or of
what with the distance and confuse oh
sorry yeah I said the distance is that
there are 1 distance yeah between the
two words between the two the words
without family either have yeah oh just
between the two rows actually so so if
you looked at their full matrix or if
you look at some estimate based on some
sample I see all right now what's the
error that's introduced by doing the
same
yes which is a tool towards so the elbe
distance between keywords and we can
account for like a very high sparsity so
that's the that's a point so it's a
reasonably low idea words I mean if you
try looking at the words which are
present in very few documents which are
very starting to deal with yeah that's
yeah that's that's very reasonable
concern and they're the reason that
because it with the data are extremely
sparse the the dimension is actually not
it's not not a lot you see anymore its
dimensionally actually much smaller so
you actually really need to think about
that dimension the actual actual
dimensions that over there does a parent
dimension yes as you notice any actual
dimension is the number of occupied
columns yeah yes number now 0 Connors
basically yeah and so the columns are so
yeah give it yeah for both words you're
saying it's wrong yeah because the
signal is very weak a much weaker now so
you estimation become harder yeah so
it's uh yeah it's yeah it's going to be
it's gonna be a problem for the chimney
password but my guess is that even even
for that Eunice boss you can afford like
a point one like ten percent tempo
improvement is still going to be
considerable vigor like you will not be
able to have the little beta it's very
very smart yeah no it's yeah yeah but
for that you don't really need you don't
need wait and eat you those faster'n
projections right yeah so so that's yeah
okay so should I move on I have a
problem just imagine okay we already
seen this that won't do it so so let's
quickly move to the what is the
limitation of doing stable and
possessions first it does not take
advantage of Dennis paucity as everyone
already know about it so does so that's
a part we have problem with as only for
the l alpha distance and suppose you do
the l2 projections you're not going to
work for the l1 so you have to start
over for every offer and so that's not
good and it's only going for is gone
it's only going for
for the pairwise distances because and
the sum of the application that database
if we want a motorway distances and it's
not going to be applicable here and and
they in some other papers we rewrote
that actually works pulley for those
most important case and I yeah I can
hear you're often likewise works pulley
yeah so so because this is dis
limitations so we want to move on to a
better scheme which is designed for
sparse data so this is not the skin
called conditional random sampling and
that the work start actually the
brothers work and the in 1997 this can
consider as a seminal work so so he's he
do this for approximating the pairwise
with the ambulance distance and he
applied that for clustering the web
pages and remove duplicates in the auto
Vista and collections and the later they
moved to move to the moon white sketch
which is a we consider that we view that
as a sample with replacement variant and
it's and but in 2005 we iono can had a
paper and the developer this and extend
this broader sketches to an example
contingency tables that means instead of
a steamy resemblance we estimated
contingency tables and they actually
reduce the variance per hectare have a
factor too then later we extend out to
motorway associations so this is going
to appear computation linguistics and
recently the work on nips is about the
general data how to use this scheme for
liquor real value data and the
histograms and the motorway air alpha
norms so so this is how it works so
suppose we start with a sparse matrix
and the so it's called the color mean is
non zero and each the car colin has the
same color so it's highly supposed to
hide a sparse i can add your house parts
but suppose a highly sports and the
first thing to do do a random
permutation of the comments
and so and then we just store all the
non-zeros so we grew up all the
non-zeros together called postings and
then we don't store the postings
completely at least in memory so let's
cut off the posting this it doesn't have
to be straight line but I will told that
it's better to use a straight line in
the presentation yeah so so let's use a
straight line so then we just get the
sketches so so you can see that the
color is so each column they have
different colors that means they're from
different columns so they're not the
random coordinates Anthony well familiar
with so but and so we so we're going to
show that how to get the random coding
examples from sketches which is
basically the front approach things so
there's a procedure okay okay so so
let's look at more concrete example so
suppose we had data matrix let's only
look out two rows so so suppose a common
I already rented / muted and so so the
data are highly spiced suppose and has
some a few non zeros and then we because
we don't need to store there's zero so
let's storm the non-zeros so we need to
use the ID which is the the kana ID and
the value which is a value in that entry
in that common so the two and three
means the second Connor the value is 3
so they are equivalent obviously because
the restaurant now zeros then this is of
course people user every day for as an
inverted index and and they're so let's
let's say how to do how do we how do we
do sampling so first first let's look at
how do we do like when the coordinate
sampling Sosa posts so these are the
data matrix not so the the arrangement
data matrix in order to get a random
code in the example because they already
rendered commuted so the only thing is
so the simple thing you can do is let's
take the front make a BS next 10
comments as render coding examples so
this is a perfect random sample and
according example
but we don't do that we do we work with
sketches so so this is the postings the
whole thing is the posting but the
sketches are the blue box so the brood
box are our sketch and we compare the
sketch is that with the with the blue
box here at your green not colorblind in
it the color is green it's a green box
and we can see that they're almost
identical except if we remove the last
elements 11 3 there would be identical
then he could because the rest of them
are zeros so this Missy why the
identical needs in example like connant
and the value tube and the common a has
a value 1 and the rest of me loves eros
so they are actually identical that
means if we just take the minimum of the
last comma ideal at 10 11 which is 10 so
it's the equivalent to sample from the
first 10 first 10 comments of the
community data matrix so so now we just
open take a random sample of size of 10
from sketches on the status of fire and
then when when the sample whether that
are much more sparse so this this ratio
10 over 5 can be maybe a ten maybe
become much more significant so we use a
small sketch to get a big size or end of
samples so that's what effect you reduce
the variance because the sample much
larger equivalently and but we have to
do this but we do know the sample size
in advance only during the estimation
stage you will know that but before that
we don't know that's why I called
conditional random sampling it's the old
analysis is conditional on the sample
size which we do not know beforehand and
we have to do this a trick every every
pair so it's appear wise a random is not
verbally randazza pairwise random and
the sample size different pair wise so
this way it takes advantage of the
sparsity an adaptive a pair wise manner
and it doesn't have to pair wise you can
be like a three-way wise
okay so that's why it's flexible because
you get a random samples and we know
that statistically become much easier
when you have random samples and people
can do then we can do sadistic on top of
a conditional random sampling and so for
example we can do smoothing you're going
to basic analysis since we have a random
samples from sketches so so that's so
that's advantage you would consider well
how do you have then next question how
do I asked me what which is very easy
because it contains a condition random
sample pairwise and then we just compute
the context summary statistics sample
summary statistics from the conditional
random samples and x D over D s what's
different TS is different pair wise so
we do this estimation pairwise so these
different pair wise but it doesn't
doesn't matter because we only care
about pairwise or three we do threeway
wise or for weight wise so and the the
thing I'm not going to talk about we can
actually improve the estimates often
considerable by taking advantage of the
margins yeah we had a couple of papers
on that but I'm not going to talk about
here and what what I want to show you
that is actually works more accurately
than stable and the projections so for
example in the buna data case and you
can know what the neighbor says just
says that the value is always less than
1 that means the variance is less than a
less than one reason why a stable random
projections is that the staple random
projections may be choosing 0 0 count
columns is that right
spasm yeah just right yeah the stapler
and a projection they don't consider the
sparsity there's no matter what your
data is i will give you and I will ever
give you good estimates in other words
you you ahead of time you decide which
columns uganda yeah yeah yeah my search
f0 accounts yeah so this is the price
you pay if you yeah if you don't you
don't no don't have the prior knowledge
of the data so so that's why what's yeah
maybe five more minutes here yeah yeah
so so in the boolean data and it's it's
it's the pupil so I hope you can visit
eyes actually it's always a more
accurate than stable and projection
because bullying that had there not so
have you tell the rest bars and this is
actually a lot better in spooning data
and for the empirical that empirical
comparison this is a NSF abstract data
so it looks like an overwhelmingly
better because that data sets will
highly sparse and the of course we only
choose a favorite favorable data sets to
compare with so so so for that data sets
and we compared with the l1 projection
and as well as their two projections and
it works like overwhelmingly better this
so this number means ninety-nine point
nine five percent of pairs condition
event is happening gives better results
yeah okay so yeah should I just skip
this or so what for people who familiar
with the broader sketches your pro lots
of words here so broader sketches is for
removing duplicate pages in the other
Vista which is like a 30 million pages
at that time now it's much more and the
heat heated similar things so he passed
the data we see page before machine goes
which is a which is a which is a sad in
this you did in this in this in this
side which is subset of this stuff so
it's basically boolean data for 44
four brothers sketches and the so he he
defined the similarity as a resemblance
which is a union / intersection of a
union so here the intersection we can
represent by their intercession and the
margins so he's generally the general
and implementation as we did then if
they store this case smallest they could
k smallest of the permuted sets as at
the sketches and he used this
complicated form and took me why you
understand why this works but it's very
clever idea so this is unbiased
estimator of the resemblance is that
yeah so maybe mobile concrete so let's
see example so let's suppose so p 1 p 2
us our postings and they already
promoted and then we take the sketchy at
the first of seven it's okay so sadly in
this case so this is a broader sketches
because because he's in buna doubt how
we want to need the ID number so it the
value is 0 the value is 1 so and the so
Bunyan and so brother sketches k1 and k2
so basically in the blue box and he used
this operation called me k operation
means a k1 over Union k2 and take the
smallest k of it and this basically
throw away half of the samples in order
to get unbiased estimator have to do a
half of the samples then after after
that he estimated that the resemblance
at the 107 so so the key is that he only
used half of the samples and the inner
together unbiased estimator and what do
we do we do we do we still do the same
limitation and we do the same sketch
however we get a conditional sample size
negative DSU can minimal over 18 which
is 18 / 19 I mean 18 or 21 so 18 we're
so therefore we remove or 19 or 21 after
we remove that we get a conditional end
of samples so therefore we're using
we're using a 12 samples instead of
seven so we always use a more sample
that's why we
better estimates and and the notice that
we enough skiing we can use different
different sample size because there's no
restriction not skiing but in produce
gadget they have to use the same because
otherwise the theoretical answer is
going to be problem so so this is a
theoretical comparisons that our methods
much better is less than 1 because of
the various theoretical variance is less
than 1 and the ratio of theoretical
variance less than 1 and empirically we
improve the misc where Miss square
errors by negative 6 negative for
example fifty percent or seventy percent
of eighty percent for empirical data you
can only improve one hundred percent so
if you want to improve eighty percent
probably very good so so nopee summer is
that in pune data are all going to use
the same sketchy but condition when a
sampling is sharper estimates by half
inter variance roughly and the wheel
does not require a fixed sample size and
these crs naturally works for general
real value data and there is also
naturally work for the motorway motorway
data and that is probably hard to define
what is our motor resemblance but for
motor we associations very natural and
the CIS can be viewed at general purpose
sampling algorithm it can replace them
the usual rain according the sampling
and we can do things on top of that so
this is a laptop to today and I still
have the summer and summer your summer
is so so some of the talk is that we
have too much data or the net net not
enough and a distance based on methods
are popular and so is often necessary
consider and there are often or other
than air to norms because that are heavy
tail and the exact computation not
feasible to time-consuming so two
methods we propose are useful for
compact data representations and
efficiently computing the distances and
the naive rent according the sampling
does not work too well because of data
often heavy tail or highly sparse and we
propose two methods they brand
projection conditioner
the sampling and our recommendation is a
staple and condition of NS mpany is
going to be good for four spots largest
pasta and it could stay Brenda
projections and conditional random
sampling is recommended for a larger
sparse data and stable random
projections the beautiful theories and
how usefully that I think it depends on
applications so that's it so thank you
very much